cette information apprendre avec
beaucoup de précaution la Russie accuse
très officiellement l'Ukraine d'avoir
voulu assassiner Poutine qui avait
relancé de drones la nuit dernière
au-dessus du Kremlin les engins ont été
neutralisés la présidence dénonce une
tentative d'acte terroriste mais assure
que le président va bien il était
d'ailleurs loin du Kremlin lors de
l'attaque il maintient le défilé
militaire du 9 mai prochain il n'y a pas
d'hommage matériel
Bruno Darou Kiev n'a pas réagi ce sont
des accusations qui émanent seulement de
la présidence russe attention parce que
on est aussi dans une guerre de
l'information oui absolument guerre de
l'information ou de la désinformation
comme c'est souvent le cas lors d'un
conflit de part et d'autre il faut le
dire mais disons qu'avec les Russes on a
un peu plus de mal à y voir clair parce
que la stratégie est un peu moins claire
que que celle des Ukrainiens témoins
donc ces allégations de la part de
Moscou comme quoi effectivement deux
drones Ukrainiens
se sont abattus sur le Kremlin en pleine
nuit alors apparemment il y a une vidéo
il y a des images qui tournent il y a
des images qui tournent pour l'instant
elles n'ont pas été authentiques voilà
elles n'ont pas été authentifiées elles
n'ont pas été vérifiées il faudrait déjà
pour transformer cette allégation en
information
avéré voir déjà peut-être c'est les
restes de ces deux drones là dans cette
vidéo il y aura une fumée enfin bon pour
le moment on n'a pas encore les images
si c'est vrai de toute façon si c'est
vrai
c'est un peu inquiétant pour Vladimir
Poutine d'une certaine manière ça veut
dire que deux drones Ukrainiens peuvent
traverser quand même une bonne partie du
territoire risque russe pour aller
frapper le Kremlin alors même si
Vladimir Poutine ne s'y trouvait pas
même si selon beaucoup de politologues
spécialistes de la Russie il s'y trouve
rarement voir quasiment jamais surtout
depuis le début de l'invasion à grande
échelle de l'Ukraine quand même le
symbole c'est à dire que deux drones
ukrainien puissent frapper le Kremlin si
c'est vrai c'est pas très rassurant pour
tous ceux qui sont chargés de surveiller
l'espace aérien russe
si c'est faux voilà si c'est faux quel
est le but recherché à ce moment-là on
est on est dans de la propagande de la
part de la Russie on voit assez
clairement que le but c'est un peu de à
la fois de de optimiser d'héroïser
Vladimir Poutine de destiné aussi
peut-être de ressouder la population
derrière lui cette fois-ci les
Ukrainiens ont voulu viser le chef et
donc en visant le chef et bien ils vise
les intérêts vitaux de la Russie et donc
ça renforce la justification du conflit
en Ukraine une autre option un peu plus
prosaïque c'est de dire voilà le chef
même Vladimir Poutine et menacé alors
qu'encore une fois très clairement et ça
a été très renforcé depuis le début de
l'invasion de l'Ukraine
Vladimir Poutine on sait jamais vraiment
où il se trouve
visiblement et dans un état de grande
paranoïa bon donc c'est très difficile
de localiser mais il y a un moment où il
va devoir être géolocalisé si je puis
dire c'est lors de ce défilé du 9 mai
voilà qui commémore la grande victoire
de l'armée soviétique sur le nazisme
alors l'an dernier il était là
est-ce que cette opération si c'est de
la propagande est-ce que russe est-ce
que cette
allégation
permettrait de dire finalement il y aura
le défilé parce que ça c'est je pense
que c'est impensable qu'il n'y ait pas
un défilé parce que là ça veut dire que
la Russie est voilà c'est pour ça qu'on
oui oui on vient de dire que c'est
les agences russes annonce vraiment le
maintien à Moscou malgré cette attaque
très humaine donc le définit militaire
d'une très très lié malheureusement on
est un peu dans le cynisme
informationnel
il y a la la légation sur ces deux
drones contre le Kremlin les agences
russes qui disent le défilé maintenu
alors le défilé maintenu mais si jamais
Vladimir Poutine n'y est pas présent
physiquement bah on pourra dire bah oui
raison de sécurité vous avez vu ce qui
s'est passé la semaine dernière on a
voulu tuer Vladimir Poutine donc là il
n'y participera pas donc ça pourrait
être un coup monté donc ça peut tout est
possible à l'heure où on c'est pour ça
qu'on va se prenant parce que par
exemple pour revenir au fait que si
c'est vrai les experts disent que les
Ukrainiens ont des drones qui
techniquement peuvent traverser ces
quelques centaines de kilomètres qui
séparent l'Ukraine de Moscou bon mais
encore une fois c'est pas très bon signe
moi j'entends beaucoup d'autres
commentaires on dit ouais on assiste
uniquement sur le côté héroïsation de la
lumière Poutine la Russie quand même
attaquer dans son cœur etc ce qui
pourrait aussi justifier alors mettre VF
n'a pas encore parlé de record à
l'harmonucléaire mais en tout cas une
frappe normalement voilà de la Russie
oui
le fait de frapper la capitale
directement Kiev et peut-être même la
présidente
ukrainienne et peut-être même le
Président zenenski vous voyez on a voilà
on est dans toutes ces hypothèses là
mais il faut toujours en tout cas il
faut toujours se rappeler que le
narratif russe comme on dit depuis le
début de cette invasion à grande échelle
se nourrit toujours
de d'arguments c'est-à-dire être aussi
une manière de renforcer les de
resserrer les rangs des Russes oui ça
peut être aussi voilà
renforcer le narratif donner un nouvel
argument il y avait les le méchant
Occident avec l'OTAN qui veut encercler
la Russie bon ok c'est pour ça qu'on a
lancé le
l'invasion et là aujourd'hui il y a le
fait que et ben maintenant les
Ukrainiens soutenus par les Occidentaux
n'hésite pas en s'en prendre à vouloir
tuer Vladimir Poutine donc ça si c'est
pas une raison non seulement poursuivre
la guerre mais aller frapper plus fort
l'Ukraine si bien sûr c'est une raison
voilà on en est là pour l'instant et
bien vous reviendrez on verra mieux ça
se développe merci en tout cas pour ces
hypothèses et ses pistes brun